through all the controversy William and
Kate are still going about their
business
today the princess and Prince of Wales
split up attending separate events
across the Boston area no one asked
about the drama of the last three days
yeah they were booed by some Celtics
fans amid his Godmother's racism Scandal
and of course Harry and Megan's
publicity machine overshadowed the visit
when promos for both the Invictus games
and their Netflix vacuum series were
released
when the stakes were this High doesn't
it make more sense to hear our story
from us
Bud willing Kate carry on
she hit Harvard Solo in houndstooth
signing the visitor's book just like
Charles did in 1986 but Kate appeared to
get tripped up with her jam-packed
schedule
William met up with Caroline Kennedy her
son jack and daughter Tatiana to tour
John F Kennedy's Presidential Library
he braved the cold to meet President
Biden before reuniting with Kate to cap
off their trip with his so-called Super
Bowl moment tonight's earthshot prize
Awards
Billy eilish Chloe and Halle Bailey and
Annie Lennox are among the performers
presenters include Rami Malek Catherine
O'Hara Shailene Woodley and Will's
friend and fellow Brit David Beckham I
grew up in a household of royalists
brought me up to be a huge royalist and
a fan of the Royal Family
[Music]